for the organizer to allow me to
participate in this workshop that has
been very stimulating it is in the
context of the longer program that is
called foundation of data science and it
would be nice maybe for us to have a
discussion of what data science really
means one idea that has helped me think
through it quite a bit in the last few
months or so is this notion the data
science should be an intelligent and
trustworthy data analysis in a world
where we collect data first and a lot of
it and then ask questions later and
there's many things that are reflected
in this order of data collection for
example the difficulty of doing
causality statements because most of the
data that is collected first is going to
be observational there is also implicit
the fact that very often we learn from
the data what questions to ask and so
there is a whole branch of inductive
data analysis that poses a lot of
theoretical interesting questions that
these audience might want to address I
want to focus on a very specific version
of that and give you an example in which
sense we can learn which questions to
ask from the data and some of the
challenges that we encounter and
contributions that we have in this
direction so I work with biomedical data
and in biomedical data data acquisition
is still costly so we don't have
gigantic sample sizes as in other fields
the way we have experienced the Big Data
revolution is that we have high
throughput measurements so we measure
very many variables and very often a
modern scientific investigations start
by testing a large collection of
hypotheses that are somewhat loosely
formulated they are not derived by prior
evidence but they are really trying to
collect every book every possible
relationship between the variables that
we measure while we do testing this is
really an exploratory endeavor in the
sense that the rejections are not going
to result in providing one drug or not
to a patient's but they are really used
as a way of identifying I
is that our warrant follow-up still
because we do so many tests it is
meaningful to correct some measure of
global error it's okay to follow up some
false leads but you don't want the
majority of the things that you follow
up to be false so a criteria for global
error that fits the bill of this context
is the false discovery rate which I'll
remind you is the expected value of the
proportion of false discovery over total
number of discovers and I have rewritten
it here explicitly this way to emphasize
that there's two averaging going on here
one we do the expected value over all
the possible realization so we don't
give a guarantee on the false discovery
proportion on these particular data sets
but all you're an average over all the
possible data sets that we might have
collected but also we don't give
guarantees on specific rejections but
was only on the average of these
rejections so what is the thing I want
to point your attention to is in many
settings like this it's often the case
that the rejections that we obtain are
not a fine product final problem what do
I mean is that they do not represent
scientifically distinct discoveries so
in order to articulate a meaningful
message in the paper or in the ground
that you write for follow-up or whatnot
some filtering is in order let me give
you a couple of examples this is a
picture from an fMRI study of
schizophrenia and a 2d rendering of it
in these cases you do a test for each
voxel and voxels are these a little cute
where you do measurements and now we
only see squares and you get an answer
for each box of saying yes there is an
association between activity and this
voxel and the trade that you are looking
at so you get an answer for each of
these little squares I don't know if you
can pick up the squares here but voxels
don't have any biological meaning
so when you have answers like this you
think well there is something going on
here I don't really care that there are
50 or 30 little squares that colored up
here they are just pointing out to one
particular religion so if you want to
describe your discoveries you might
describe saying oh I have this know nine
areas where I seen some activation this
is the same setting in an area where I
work a lot which is genome-wide
Association studies simpler instead of
being in 3d is just 1d we have on the
x-axis the genome and you test for
association between a genetic
polymorphic mini genetic polymorphisms
about 1 million of them and the
phenotype of interest and what do you
have in this plot our minus log 10 the
p-value so some sense of the strength of
association that you detect and each dot
correspond to a different genetic
polymorphic and what you can see is that
when you see Association it typically
shows up not just at one snip at one of
these polymorphous but at many of them
now when you're going to report the
findings
you're not going to report every single
one of these snips saying oh I have
found an association between snip 1 2 3
& 4
and in this case this is glaucoma but
you're going to report an association
between glaucoma and this particular
locus here you cannot make up out the
names but the scientists here have
identified different genes that are in
this different lock site often if you
cannot identify the gene what your
report is simply the snip that has the
smallest p-value and you use it as an
indicator of that particular locus this
is the more complicated for me to
describe examples but I'm an interesting
one and it refers to a new type of
studies that it's becoming popular that
it's called the--was so you test for
association between one exposure or in
this case one particular Appleton HLA
Apple type and every possible disease
Under the Sun how could you possibly do
that you rely on cohorts of
individuals that you have for example
all the patients of a hospital or all
the people that are taken care by a
health maintenance organization of skies
are permanent or all the insurance that
a particular insurance so you imagine
that on these people you can measure the
exposure or the genotype here and see if
you can see association between this
exposure and any of the diseases and how
do you represent any of the diseases in
this type of data the diseases are
represented using what we called ICD
code so this international
classification of diseases that has a
tree structure and for example if we
look down here this node here in court
incorporates all the diseases of the eye
and neighboring areas and then you get
more specific to different neighboring
areas so for example here you have the
cornea and something else and then you
say which type of diseases of the
various area so this is glaucoma and
then you have different type of glaucoma
the colors in these plots indicate the
strength of the detected associations so
darker green means that you have seen a
stronger association and white that you
have seen no association at all
so let's look at the top here you see
lots of these nodes are associated now
if you are able to swim there you see
that this one RF all kind of spondylitis
which is an inflammation of the spine
and you really don't want to report that
you have association with spondylitis
ace from the latest B's from the DTS 3
and maybe a generic spondylitis there is
only one type of association that you
have seen so you want to collapse
somewhat summarize your results ok so
what I'm going to do next is to show you
a few cartoon examples to convince you
that some of the rules that we may use
to summarize and filter down these
results have impact on FDR control and
then introduce you to a method that we
have developed that aisle keeps FDR
control when we focus on selecting
discoveries now while all the mistakes
in blonde
are mine this is worth that I did in
collaboration with Jean tax-evasion
marina Bogomolov marina Bogomolov hits
on the faculty at the Technion and i
have worked with her for a few years and
learned a tremendous amount about SDR
controlling procedures from her and gene
cuts which it's a graduating student at
Stanford with whom I had the privilege
to work he is also here today so I also
have the privilege to defer to him any
technical questions that you might have
so here it's my cartoon version of the
brain so let's say that each squares
here represents an hypothesis that we
want to test and we are going to
identify the non null hypothesis with an
Asterix so those are the discovery we
might want to make and now let's say
that we do testing and we have an FDR
controlling procedure at the 10% and my
rejection set is represented by the
iportal by the square that I call our
new pink so if you are quick at counting
you'll see that you have 48 pink squares
so 48 discoveries five of those are
false and so your realize FDP it's
really quite close to the 10 percent
target now if we sit our brain study we
really don't want to report all of these
48 discoveries are distinct so what we
might we might identify clumps of
ideation discoveries and say well I'm
going to report with more weight one of
them and the other one down wave them a
little bit so that I really have one
separate discovery for each clamp
without forgetting the other ones and
the way I put down weights here is that
you have it value of 20 21 for total
weight discoveries for way to false
force discovery so your false discovery
proportion gets down gets up to a me 19
percent say that you select only one of
those discoveries from each Club okay so
you look at the clamps and then you
select one representative discovering
this is what
and here now you have 12 filtered
discoveries and four of those are false
so your false discovery proportion and
now it's up to 30% okay so I haven't
changed my testing I simply have
filtered down my set of discoveries to
really come up with distinct one that
makes sense reporting let's look at a
problem that looks a little bit more
like the ICD code setup so here my
hypotheses are on a tree and parents
hypotheses are equal to the intersection
of the children hypothesis and in my
coding actual null hypothesis is
represented by a circle and the false
null is represented by a square so
suppose I do some testing and I indicate
with the rejections with a red border
say these are my rejections I now have
an realize force discovery proportion of
3 over 14 now there is some redundancy
here right because if I have discovered
H for H 5 H 6 & 8 7
of course I have discovered age 16 is
just the intersection of those I don't
need to report all of these findings so
what has been proposed even back in 2008
by Danny acutally and other colleagues
is to say when you have a setting like
this what you should report are the
outer nodes so the discoveries that are
not parent to any other discoveries the
outer nodes of the discoveries in this
graph are the nodes shaded in blue so
say that I do that my false discovery
proportion which was already pretty high
in this example raises now to 3 out of 9
so I hope I have convinced you that
while the Adaro it's true that if
something is true it's safe so no matter
how you slice it when you in allow some
noise to contaminate your discoveries
how you slice this discovery does matter
and I'm not just wanting to play an own
language emphasizing that when something
is true you can do this it's also
relevant to understand that if we use as
a target error rate something like
family-wise error
we have no problems okay because we're
guaranteeing ourselves that the
probability would which make even one
false discoveries very small so we can
regroup our finding in any way we like
and we'll still be fine
but when we use a more lenient criteria
like the false discovery rate which is
really a statement on the average of the
discoveries that I make how I count
these discoveries better and how I slice
them matters now this problem has been
noted before and in fact if you look at
the literature for FDR control in MRIs
and functional MRIs or some beautiful
work the pro-pro specific solution there
it had been noted before in the context
of genome scans and um my colleague
David Sigmund and Nancy J and so on have
contributions there we don't have really
solutions for the problem of controlling
false discovery rate on outer note yet
but what we want to do is to look at
this problem at the general level and
propose a general purpose procedure that
allow us to help FDR guarantees on the
finding that will actually report so to
do that let's take a step back and then
look at the problem in somewhat abstract
fashion now this is as matthean audience
as I ever get to address so I'm sure
this will not be problematic for you but
there's a little bit of notation in the
next slide so bear with me for a little
bit so we start having our m.i potus's
and what we want to do is to say okay
maybe we do testing but testing is not
the end of the story then we are going
to filter our rejections maybe we are
going to associate different weights to
them so let's formalize this using this
notion of the prioritization vector so
you have for each hypothesis a value UJ
that it's a number between 0 & 1 that
represents what you are going to do with
these hypotheses it's 0 if you are going
to forget about it I think you think
it's not interesting at all and it can
be a number that tells you how much
money you are going to invest in
following it up how much space you are
going to give it in
paper in standard multiple testing these
numbers corresponds to 0 or 1 0 if you
do not reject a thought this is one if
you reject it and what we are saying is
that if you want to incorporate all type
of repair authorization that people do
on their party this is useful to have a
continuum value if we look at the outer
node filtering what are these use are
simply you are getting u equals there
the user only 0 and 1 and you are going
to be 1 if you are rejected and if you
are in the outer node set of the
rejections to give you an example of you
that it's not actually 0 or 1 you can
think about waiting multiple testing and
being a minion heart rate for example in
97 have introduced a procedure that does
FDR controlling and waiting setting so
there you have for each hypothesis prior
to do any testing you have a weight that
represents how important for you that I
parties is is how costly would be to
make a wrong choice with respect to that
particular hypothesis and in that
context our views are equal to the
weight that you decide a priori and then
multiply by the indicator that tells you
that hypothesis it's in the rejection
set or not we're using this capital u
because generally speaking our use our
random variable that whose outcome will
be determined using on the data okay so
if use are incorporating all what we are
going to do with about these hypothesis
our global error that we should target
whose control we should time that should
be defined in terms of this use so we
have this generalized FTP which is just
like the usual FTP instead of looking at
use here you put an hour indicator that
tells you is rejected or not but what we
have the denominator it's the total
weighted amount of discoveries and that
of the numerator the proportion the
fraction of the total weighted amount of
discovery that pertains to notes
there are many ways in which one could
come up with these new prioritization
rules what we're going to focus on our
prioritization rules that are defined by
filtering rejections so we're going to
look at the setting where we have some
multiple comparison procedure gives us
some rejection set and then we filter
these rejection sets so let me tell you
precisely what I mean with filter so
filter it's a function that takes as
input a rejection set and the data or
really what we do is P values and then
outputs for you a prioritization vector
so for each of the hypotheses you have
these values U and what we require is
that U is 0 if the iPod if u J is 0 if
the J hypothesis is not in the rejection
set so what this is saying is that you
take a rejection set and you concentrate
on a subset of it or your you waited a
bit differently and we have seen two
type of filters the clumping filter it's
what I described for you roughly for the
brain type data so you denta Phi
clusters of neighboring rejections and
then you select one representative from
this cluster of neighboring rejections
typically you might pick the one that
has the smallest p-value and the outer
node filter I hope I managed to explain
to you what that is okay so what is the
goal that we want to pursue well so we
want suppose we have a multiple testing
procedure M that gives us some rejection
set and a filter F so this filter and
multiple comparison procedure give us
this prioritization vector what we want
it's a procedure that guarantees that
the expected value of this generalized
FD p on this product ization vector is
controlled and we call this object false
filter discovery rate and since out I'm
sure I'll say filters for FDR because
it's easier to say but ok well we're
looking it's the FDR on this final set
of rejections
how are we going to have develop a
procedure that does that well we are
going to modify ever so slightly the
being a mini Hochberg procedure so let
me restate for you what the being a mini
hot sure procedure does so that it's
easy for me to see where we modified
okay one way of saying when being a mini
Hotel does is say we have a set of P
values and then we consider a series of
possible rejection sets
index by value T that is the threshold
on the p value that you might consider
so these rejection set t is the set of
hypotheses whose p value is smaller than
equal then T for each of these possible
rejection sets we estimate the false
discovery proportion how do we do that
well the false discovery proportion is
the number of discovery at the
denominator denominator and at the
numerator the number of false
discoveries which we don't know so we
need to estimate and this is the
estimate we had in the Benjamin Hodge
procedure so lo and behold for every T I
have an FD p estimate and what my
procedure tells me to do is to look for
the maximum value with maximum T such
that the estimator definitely it's lower
than my level Q and then I'm going to
output as rejection the rejection set
associated to that T star so what we
need to do is to work on this estimate
of the false discovery proportion
because this estimate of the false
discovery proportion is corresponding to
my initial rejection set okay I want it
to be an estimate of the false discovery
proportion in my final outcome okay I
don't want it to be an estimate of the
FDP on our back of this generalize
everything so what do I let's look at it
a little bit more in detail the little
mediator is simply the count of the
number of rejections and a denominator I
have an estimate of the number of nulls
than you know a boundary
estimate than assume that all the
hypotheses are null and my p-values are
well behaved and so on I need to change
the denominator okay because I'm going
to change them if you remember what
happens when I do my cartoons I change
the total count of rejections and it
diminishes so that's what I need to do I
need to do modify the denominator to
incorporate this different way of
counting I could also change the
numerator because in fact I count
differently also the numerator but
that's more difficult and it's really a
matter of power it's not a matter of
controlling the FDR so we don't do that
right away so this is the procedure that
we know when we change the denominator
of the FDP instead of having the total
number of rejections in the intermediate
rejection set I simply plug in the sum
of my hue values so this gives me
exactly the same procedure a procedure
that looks exactly like the end so
that's why we call it hocus b8 and we
call it focus because instead of it
gives a guarantee on the focused set of
discovery we focus on this particular
way of looking at what is important
according to the filter to give you a
sense of what these does let me tell you
what it's equivalent to in a simpler
setting suppose you had a my potus's and
you say are now going to test them all
I'm going to only focus on the 10 and
the 100 I parties that have the smallest
p-values then say that you want to have
FDR control on the rejections that you
have you cannot apply BH to these 100 i
parties it as level two right because
you already started selecting your
hypothesis as those ones that have the
smallest p-value you surely think that
you have to pay some price for this
election right otherwise I always play
this game I say oh I want to focus on
the one hypothesis that has the smallest
p-value and now my alpha level is just
alpha I don't have to pay any price so
you must pay some price and it turns out
that the palace you have to pay is that
you can work on this set of only a
hundred I part of this but what you need
to do is to do B H on this set
with the target that it's 0.05 it's
point two five is the target you have in
mind
times a hundred over n so you pay a
penalty for how selective you have been
in your initial pass now the focus being
H if you apply to a setting like this
and you work out what does this mean in
terms of filter gives you exactly this
procedure ok so when does it work to
state one of the results that we have I
have to tell you what is the monotonic
prioritization rule well it's a yet
another definition that is a very simple
concept suppose you have two sets of
p-values and you can compare them so
that in one set each p value is smaller
than the other one a monotonic
prioritization rule tells you that when
you have smaller p value you have more
overall discovers so if your filter is
such that your prioritization rule is
monotonic and the p values you have a
PRDS then we can prove that focus BH
controls the folder the false filter
discovery rate at the level that we want
okay now a cute thing is that outer
nodes induce a monotonic fertilization
rule on trees so with this result we can
control the width now have it provable
procedure that control the false
discovery rate on outer node and this is
the contribution to the literature
because there wasn't any really known
procedure that did that in fact we the
the procedure I described for you does a
little bit more not only we control the
FDR on the filtered set but we also
control the FDR in the intermediate
rejection so if I think about the gos
example this tells me that I control the
FDR of the different loss I that I
identify but I'm also allowed to go and
look at all the snipped the past the
initial threshold and consider these
larger more fine-grained description of
where the Association is and now if
we relax the hypothesis in the p-value
so if we assume the DP values are
independent or block independent so if
we make stronger assumption on the
p-value assuming that they are
independent or block independent then we
can relax the hypothesis on the filter
and we can also deal with filters that
are not monotonic as I am I spoke here I
got a question about what is P RDS so I
have these details here if anybody asks
me the question we'll go back to that so
um I told you we don't modify the
numerator but the fact that we do not
modify the numerator tells us that my
estimate that I have it's conservative
and it's conservative for two reason as
every BH procedure its assumes that it's
a bound under the hypothesis that every
null hypothesis is true and also it
doesn't account for the filtering so if
I'm filtering my reject so I'm certainly
diminishing the number of rejections
much I might as I Wells diminish the
number of false rejections and we don't
account for that either now accounting
for the first one is easy we can do a
story like procedure and estimate the
number of nano's and we can prove that
these words if the p-values are
independent which is typically what you
can prove for story like procedure
accounting for the filtering gets more
complicated and we don't quite know how
to do it the only way we have outlined
is to use some permutations and these
are slide that I don't expect you to
read
we don't have results that say that
permutation really give us theoretical
control of the FDR it's very difficult
to have any results and if they are
controlled based on permutation but in
our simulations this works quite well so
there is room for improving power a
little bit and permutation seems to be a
viable one so let me show you a couple
of simulations to give you a sense of
what's going on so the first one it's a
set up where we have hypotheses as
noting a tree
and in this setup the leaf nodes here
correspond each to one gene and we say
that an hypothesis is not null if this
gene is differentially expressed between
cases and controls and the data that
we're going to generate has 10 100 cases
and 100 controls in each parent know
what is the intersection of the children
node so in the setup here we've decided
that these four genes are truly
differentially expressed and all the
ancestors of these four leaf nodes are
then nano's because we have this
intersection description of the parents
hypothesis the simulation all go to show
you has 500 replicates for 11 different
levels of signal strength and how do we
get P value for each node so we have a
simple p value of the leaf nodes and
every other node has a p-value that it's
obtained doing science of the P values
relative to the genes that are
descendant of that node okay so for this
one Baidu signs of these two p-value for
this one I do signs of these four P
values so what I'm going to do is to
compare the performance of focus BH with
other procedures and I want to compare
in terms of error rate and power so let
me tell you which procedures I am going
to look at and what are their advertised
error rate controls so we're going to
consider two procedures that target the
FDR on the pre-filtering steps and then
we're going to see what happens if i
take the rejections of this procedure
and apply a filter so these two
procedure rb8 or stored eh then I'm
going to consider a procedure that
actually controls the family-wise error
rate now any procedure that controls the
family-wise error rate controls the FDR
both in the pre filtering and the after
filtering step that's the nice property
of family
right it might seems arbitrary though to
compare to a family wiser oh right
controller procedure because that's a
much stringent much more stringent error
rate this particular one has been
developed for hypotheses that are on a
tree structure and help and capitalizes
on the logical relationship between
hypotheses so whenever you reject one
hypothesis you are going to add to the
rejection set all the parents or all the
ancestors of these hypotheses so it is
actually a fairly powerful procedure as
far as family-wise error rate procedures
go and then we consider two procedure
that have at least in mind the idea of
controlling these false this filtered
false discovery rate one is our the
other one is the procedure put forward
by danil acutally in fact this procedure
can probably control the FDR only when
the p-values are independent which is
typically fairly uninteresting in these
three type of hypotheses and the tech
varies its a bound and the bound has a
fairly conservative procedure we are
going to use something that Danny
acutally found in simulation works even
if it is not exactly the bound that he
has in his theoretical result so we are
using it in the most liberal version
that seems to have control fer okay so
this one's our the procedure and I'm
going to look at the false discovery
rate in the pre-filtered step set and
the pass filter set and I'm also going
to look at power and what do I mean with
power well when I do this filtering we
have to agree on what power would mean
in these contexts and what we're going
to say is that power is just the ratio
between the sum of the u j's relative to
true no to true/false nodes over the
maximum value that this sum could have
okay so if the power cannot necessarily
be all that originally non
like parties because some of this one
might get filtered out anyway when I do
my filtering so that's why we have these
tea marks business okay so there's lots
of lines here but up let me walk you
through this plot so we have FDR in the
both top panels and power in the bottom
panels and on this side we have
pre-filter and on this side post filter
so the red lines correspond to procedure
that target the pre-filter FDR and in
fact they do control it but you can see
that they lose control pause after
filtering so indeed if you simply apply
BH and then do filtering you don't have
a control you know your final results
really don't have the reproducibility
guarantee that you would like my want to
advertise them with the structured homes
it's the dark blue line and indeed it
controls F drag in both cases and the
focus BH corresponds to this set of
middle blue lines here and you can see
that they all control the FDR
pre-filtering and post filtering now
let's look at what happens in terms of
power so these red procedures have the
highest power though it's false
advertising because they don't have FDR
control in the post filtering set so of
course if you make more discoveries you
make more discoveries point it's
interesting to see what happens to the
power of the Italian structured homes
for example so equity le procedure even
if technically the conditions for his
theorems are not satisfied here does
control the FDR pre and post filtering
it has the worst power so it is not
really a very competitive procedures
besides the fact that it doesn't have
necessarily theoretical guarantees what
happened to structured homes you can see
this
tractor homes it's quite powerful here
in the pre-filtering
set in fact its power is very close to
the flowers of the focus BH procedure so
that seems a little bit counterintuitive
structured home it's controlling family
why is that all right we are controlling
as we are we end up having the same
power what kind of a joke is that that
it's due to the fact that as I told you
the structure homes enriches the
rejection set by including all the
ancestors of any rejections once you
reduce redundancy in your rejections and
you do the filter then this extra
addition of rejections doesn't play the
same trick so you can see that now in
the post filtered set the focus BH
procedures have higher power than
structured homes now what are all these
different focus BH procedures they are
the one that I have described for you
vanilla one original they are the one
that's modified to do something like
story and permutation one but they all
behave the same here so let's not look
too much at this plot except for seeing
that the permutation one for which we
have no theoretical results does seem to
control the false discovery rate another
example let me now go through the
details of how the simulation was done
let me just tell you that it's a mock
version of Aegeus
so that we generate data so that it
looks like data from snips and we have
testing for association with one
particular phenotype and because we
don't have this tree structure it
doesn't make sense to include in our
comparisons that you could clearly
procedure the structure at home so that
plot here it's a little bit simpler what
we can see is that if we do not do
anything about the filtering step we are
going to lose fvr control quite
dramatically so this is what happens if
you do BH plus filter and let's look now
this
through two filtered eh proposal this is
the original one that I have described
and this one the dashed one is the
permutation there is also a third line
here that has this very light blue
that's what's called here Oracle to say
that it's not an existing procedure yes
the filter here is the clumping filter
so identifies nibs that are neighbours
and I select from all those nibs that
are neighbors one representative which
is the snip with the smallest p-value so
this Oracle business it's not a
procedure it's a theoretical
constructions if you knew how things
were this is the best thing you could
possibly do what is interesting to see
here is the permutation one does thing
to control the full discovery rate and
it goes quite close to this maximum
possible power that we could obtain okay
and in case you like this so much and
you want to do many filters at the same
time you can we can put together many
different filters and give you a few our
control simultaneously on all of these
filters so let me conclude because FDR
it's a guarantee on the average of your
discoveries it's really tied up to water
how you count discovers and in order to
be valid any procedure really has to
account of all the selection steps that
you put into defining what are you going
to present in your paper or in your
follow up ground as the discoveries of
your study now when these correction
process of what are you going to
consider really as a relevant discovery
can be specified in advance and this is
often the case because in the setting
where we work people use algorithms you
know it's not that they are going to
look at the discoveries and on the basis
of their feeling pick one or the other
there are so many of them they just have
to specify we are going to filter them
according to this rule or this adder
rule so whenever you can
specifying advance the rule that you're
going to use to reprioritize your
discovery you can incorporate it in the
multiple comparison procedures and get
the right fvr guarantees I haven't
really talked about it too much and
partly because we haven't done too much
with it but in this process we have also
um in trying to be general and defining
what is the goal that we had in mind we
have introduced this idea that you can
give an answer about and hypothesis that
is not binary 0 or 1 but it's continuous
and the value of that continuous answer
can be entirely driven by the data so
you could you know you don't have to
specify a priori the weight of an
hypothesis but you can use the data to
decide what is the appropriate weight to
give to that I think there is potential
to do interesting things there and I
also have not talked about this but I
did emphasize that we have a nice result
on control outer nodes on trees a lot of
hypotheses that people are interested in
testing are not quite on trees but
indirectly Casilla graph that don't have
only the tree structure and we've made
some contribution to that literature as
well Eugene Katz a witch is going to
give a lightning talk this afternoon so
if you are shy and asking him questions
now you can ask him this afternoon he is
going to talk about another project that
he has done also related to FDR and he
is going to show some progress on
understanding in which sense
FDR controlling procedures are maybe
more robust than we give them credit for
thank you very much for your attention
[Applause]
delicious so if you had a priori
information on uh and signaling pathways
could you embed that in this process
in a way that you're kind of looking
along the possible genes in which did
you know the steps would be hitting
within those signaling pathways
yes I mean the what I've talked about
it's how you massage or how do you
interpret p-values that you already have
if you are thinking of you know if I
have information on the structure can I
do tests differently that it's not
incorporated in here
what it's also true that even if you
don't incorporate the information in how
you calculate the p-values you can do
testing strategies that are here article
for example so that you don't test all I
parties at the same time but you say
well I start over here and I only test
children of hypothesis that look
promising
and that's also an area in which we have
some work it's not really covered from
what I have talked about now now you can
also use that your definition of filter
you can use it to reflect some of these
information so you could say maybe my
filters are pathway aware so I'm going
to say that any discovery in a certain
pathway it's somewhat redundant to other
discoveries there so you could implement
it in that sense
maybe the bank I actually had a question
about the hierarchical is there are
these even compliment like the question
of doing like a hierarchical filtering
or screaming filter for example you have
other day you know maybe you run an
f-test to do the most interesting spots
or any new certain regions and then you
try to zoom in the sort of this kind of
strategy are they even comparable with
this framework that you've set up here
are they just completely um well could
you could even make sense to compare
them like the methods on the same
simulations or something like this today
so the setup we looked at it's where you
actually test every hypothesis and then
you have these rejections that can be
redundant if you do a testing that is
your article and says I'm only going to
test these hypotheses first and then go
down and test only I reject this one
okay then typically there you are
automatic it you are implicitly going to
forget about these hypotheses once you
move down you know you're automatically
looking at outer notes so they are
comparable in that sense but when you do
the testing your article II like that
typically you don't have this problem of
having to reduce redundancy at the end
they are compatible in the sense that
while I have used science T value to do
the p-values from for these ancestors I
could use whatever test I want here so
yes these hypotheses I could use an F
test or whatever more sophisticated test
I have to capture the signal of that
level now I say you can I'm not sure
that you have PRDS necessarily once you
have this complicated test simply
because prvs it's a complicated thing to
verify but we have done simulations in
setup where we don't have P RDS and
nothing wrong seems to happen it's you
know a fairly robust
setting it's a scientific question do
you want to do it here are a testing
there are equally versus you test
everything
I like your article testing I think if
you can think through my band would be
to try to do it that way it is true that
in many applications people don't want
to think through very much and so that's
what I mean where you learn from the
data which question to ask you start
with this list of all possible
hypotheses I could possibly test and
just afterwards you say well let me put
some order in them
yes maybe a mrs. Rita VHS special case
of this building eh actually not so it
is it is a good question
if we have a setup so you we can do
weighted I POTUS is testing with this
filter b8 but the rule that you will get
it's not exactly the rule that you would
get doing weighted b8 as its described
for example in Benjamin hotter 97 which
is the closer one to us and I think we
are a bit less powerful because since we
are treating these weights as if they
could be learned from the data we don't
manage to recuperate all the power that
it's since our V hat it's conservative
it doesn't take into account the
reduction of the number of discoveries
that the number of holes discovered that
it's also induced by filter I think we
are a little bit more conservative than
what B h97 wouldI would do in this case
but so yes you can do weighted testing
in this framework if your weights are
defined as pre a priori I think you're
better off using one of the other
procedure
all right let's thank the speaker
[Applause]